you wanna die if me dying could stop
this if we can make things different for
us for youth brothers are the kids it'd
be worth hey everybody this is gonna be
my Walking Dead midseason finale video
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen it yet obviously because it's
supposed to be such a big episode they
either blew up a bunch of people or
implied that a bunch of people were
getting ready to die by the time we come
back for episode 9
so we'll address all the Carl's stuff at
the end of the episode because even
talking dead was convinced of his fate
but I think that this is the new version
of the Glenn dumpster a much better
version if you're just finding me for
the first time be sure to subscribe to
get everything there's gonna be a whole
bunch of hardcore comic book stuff
happening before the end of the year
between this Star Wars and all the DC TV
stuff and there is a new round of the
giveaway I'll explain at the end of the
video so let's just go through top 10
WTF and comic book Easter eggs there
were a couple big foreshadowing Easter
eggs for a couple particular characters
number 10 the Carl flashbacks at the
beginning of the episode they did that
thing where they jump backwards and
forwards in time but all of Carl's
speeches were taken from that scene in
the first episode where Rick wanted to
bail on the person that Carl was trying
to help which turned out to be siddik
from the comics so what Carl's basically
telling him is that there has to be some
sort of compromise they can't just go on
killing all the Savior's because things
will wind up being just as bad even if
they're able to get rid of negan so
remember the flash-forwards to old rake
in that episode where he said my mercy
prevails over my wrath the whole idea is
is that they will have to find a
compromise with the Savior's but the
events of the episode just like how
crazy the Savior's were rubbing
everyone's faces in it they really want
you to believe like that's gonna be
impossible like it's either them or the
Savior's just the way that negan's going
on and on about what he's gonna do to
everyone even Simon rubbing Maggie's
face and everything but number 9 Aaron
and Enid side trip they sort of left
them hanging so obviously they'll have
to resolve that when we come back in
episode 9 but I do like the reminder
that Enid is actually one of the more
clever survivors because even before
this season before she met Carl she had
survived on her own for a while
because that piece of paper that he was
staring
was Enid's signature phrase just
survived somehow so just remember that
note just survived somehow karl was
staring at that so the entire episode
he's thinking about that just survive
even when he's talking to negan trying
to distract him by offering himself but
the big twist with Aaron and Edith's
storyline was great the way they
accidentally kill Cindy's grandmother
making you think that there's no way
that Oceanside's going to help them this
was all part of this steady nosedive
that they wanted the survivors to take
in the early part of the episode like
negan rolls up number 8 negan surprises
everyone in the middle of the night and
it turns out all their lookouts are gone
they have all these saviors that have
rolled up on the kingdom and the safe
zone at the same time so when he starts
yelling at them on the megaphone you've
already lost just give up now they
really want you to believe like that's
what's happened because now we might not
get any help from Oceanside they don't
have the numbers and they have this
large mobilized force of saviors that's
ready to go and they're totally
unprepared with a few minor exceptions
if you've been watching TV for a long
time though you always know its darkest
before the dawn like they really want to
make it seem like it's unwinnable so
then when Rick and the survivors
eventually rally the victory is that
much sweeter because things got so bad
for them but number 7 Maggie's roadblock
remember the last time there was a
roadblock that she rolled up on that was
the same night that negan killed Glenn
so she is triggered in Simon just lays
into her he basically gives her to the
same business that everybody else is
getting at the kingdom and at the safe
zone just telling them they're not even
indentured servants anymore they're
full-blown slaves you're gonna do what
we want when we want and we're taking
all of your nice cushy homes number six
that Carl's storyline was probably one
of the better ones in the episode he was
one of the few people that actually knew
what he was doing like each step along
the way was carefully planned so Sheriff
Carl was on his game this week so he's
just running the Savior's around in
circles in the safe zone with those
smoke bombs enough time for everybody to
get down into the sewers that's really
the whole point that was why he offered
himself up to negan although when you
really listen to him and you look at his
face he actually looks like he's ready
to die like he's being honest when he's
talking to negan even though he probably
really doesn't want to
he's still thinking about that note just
survive somehow but I love the look on
deacons face when Carl offers him up
he's like Leonardo DiCaprio and Django
Unchained you had my curiosity but now
you have my attention
but of course Carl's just leading him on
he gets really pissed off and starts
blowing up the safe zone so number five
r.i.p safe zone now negan basically told
all the Savior's there to blow up every
other building so even if they're able
to defeat negan ultimately I think what
they're telling you is it the safe zone
as a place where people live is over
they're probably gonna have to go to the
kingdom now and because so many people
will die in the next couple of episodes
it'll free up some house space so I
think that's how they're gonna explain
the group's combining so side note
during one of the ad breaks in the
middle of the episode the claimer
showed back up he said claim grab the
hatchet right out of that Walker it was
totally surprising but the other thing
too is that there was an ad break every
10 minutes in this episode for an hour
and a half so I hope AMC made all the
money they need to make because they are
burning the fans hardcore but I think
this has been a common complaint of the
Walking Dead for many years now just the
fact that they stuff so many extra add
breaks into their programs because
Walking Dead is one of the few shows
that they have that actually earns a
profit but number four Eugene tries to
undo safai himself somewhat successfully
but we all still want him to die so he
allows Gabriel in the doctor to get away
so that the doctor can deliver Maggie's
baby but the whole reason he doesn't go
with them is because he doesn't think
that they'll take him back he believes
he's beyond redemption and he's still a
bit of a coward like he's afraid to
chance it he's like oh maybe if I go
back they'll kill me on the spot and I'm
still blown away that on the other side
of that coin they haven't killed Gregory
yet he was still a total douche in the
episode - Maggie it was kind of a funny
moment - how come you're letting this
guy out didn't you properly kills him I
think the idea is is that they want you
to cheer when Gregory eventually gets
killed but Eugene they want you to feel
a little more choked up about because
there was a time when he actually wasn't
quite so bad but number three Ezekiel
sacrifices himself to the Savior's to
allow his people to get out they wanted
to feel like his soul has been say this
way he thanks Carol thank you for saving
literally saving him from death but also
saving his soul in a way so the big
comic book Easter egg is from when the
Savior say that they're going to hang
him on the fence so I don't want to get
more specific than that
but if you want to you can read ahead
and find out what happens with Ezekiel
eventually they even did the same thing
in an earlier episode when they killed
off Shiva in the episode they talk about
something that will eventually happen to
Ezekiel that was more foreshadowing for
his comic book art so we'll see if they
follow through on that but number two
was Rick vs. negan the fight didn't last
as long as I expected it to but I think
that they're dragging this out to the
second half of the season and obviously
I think that all of the back half is
going to be part two of all-out war so
it's just gonna go on with negan it's
not like they're gonna defeat him in
episode 9 and that's gonna be the end of
it it was pretty cool to see him rip
Lucille out of negan's hands but
obviously I don't think that anybody
expected Nikken to die in this episode
so it was a pretty badass escape just
jumping right out that window but how
many of you when Rick first came to the
safe zone and ran right into his house
we're just waiting for negan to step
around the corner it was so quiet - in
earlier in the episode he had been like
I'm gonna go to Rick's house and make
some spaghetti just waiting for him to
show up but they make it down into the
sewer Michonne was so great she goes
into that berserker rage but the number
one WTF obviously is the fact that karl
has been bitten it if you take them very
literally by the look on Rick and
Michonne face they think that Karl's
going to die from that bite eventually
so it's just a question of when are they
going to say goodbye is he gonna die
slowly are they gonna put him out of his
misery
but because every season everyone's
always been wondering about Karl there
was a contract renewal that came up for
Chandler Riggs awhile ago so there was
talk of him leaving the show and going
to college for a couple years like he
actually wanted to go get a college
degree so everyone's like how are they
gonna handle that will there be a time
jump what it sounds like they might do
is that this is like I said the version
of the Glenn dumpster that isn't quite
so egregious as the Glenn dumpster they
just want to make you wonder whether or
not he's gonna die during the break and
they'll find a way to transition him to
a lesser role on the show if he does end
up dying when we come back in episode 9
let me know what
your takeaway from that scene especially
given him staring at that enid phrase
just survive somehow in taking into
account the way they handle the actor in
real life like him just going off to
college and then coming back to the show
every once in a while but
congratulations to the latest IMAX
ticket giveaway winner swerve animations
please private message me so I can get
your contact details there'll be a new
round when I post my episode 9 trailer
video tomorrow so while you wait for
that click here for my new Titan season
1 arrowverse video and you can click
here for brand new Star Wars the last
Jedi thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight